ah welcome back it's 5:00 in the morning
and you know what that means
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I had to take a really
really long break after that that was so
horrible I
I watched it then I couldn't even
couldn't even comprehend words you know
I could comprehend that's not the right
word
I couldn't even say words I just said oh
my god oh my god oh my god because
that's really all I thought that moment
I I went into the [ __ ] room I was so
sure he wasn't there and then I was like
what the hell I can't move backwards and
then I returned around and there he is
hitting my face and I'm like [ __ ] it's
like he spent so many hours playing this
game trying to avoid the [ __ ] monster
and then he's right [ __ ] behind you
when you think you're [ __ ] safe it's
like I just I wasn't ready for that at
all I was hoping in this game wouldn't
you know do this to me anymore now that
I played it so many hours but it still
does this doesn't doesn't stop getting
scary it's so annoying and the thing is
when I log in now when I play select and
play that monsters gonna be there behind
me and it's gonna I got to start running
and it's gonna start chasing me and I
knew it I had to have something that
wouldn't you know
something that made me want to continue
this play playing this game because
right now as it isn't right now there
aren't many reasons for me wanting to do
this so I do come prepared now I got a
click continue yeah I'm gonna pulse it
all right when it goes in it's gonna be
so [ __ ] horrible I just ah sitting in
a dark room with a headset phone song
they have it was a great idea
[ __ ] load already mother [ __ ] I don't
want to hear that the mone again oh okay
okay I'm gonna
since he's gonna chase me I don't know
if you guys can hear it since it's gonna
chase me I am gonna put on some fading
music for it
[Music]
Oh horrible oh [ __ ] he was quick it was
much quicker than where am I
it's a prison cell I never died before
I was hoping I'd never do that I'm so
horrible
oh no I don't know where I am actually
that was I was intense no doubt no doubt
storage yeah this is where I died I died
in the same room where he was that's
weird
so I got all this stuff apparently there
was like nothing useful in here
oh geez so scary cell area five four
Oh down there or
I bet I can break this
no no I don't know why I even try that I
know it's not gonna work
storage why the [ __ ] not
so dark
hello you there already lit up
why not dead mice nice right
it's got to be something in here lots of
stuff I like that thank you
don't know why I keep wasting that what
is this
and break
Jesus Christ
so now I know he's [ __ ] quick as well
that's great oh no no I can't run when I
see him because I'll be dead otherwise
[ __ ] great everyone keep telling me
story she's like the most scariest part
so I
I'm glad this is almost almost over oh
there he is
I don't know if you can come in here
I'm so sick of you
if he comes in there I'm gonna turn the
[ __ ] computer off
I should've just went in there I just I
should have just ignored him
my stomach [ __ ] hurts I'm so [ __ ]
stressed from this play in this game
I hate this I really changed me I
honestly thought I could get away from
him sorry that was my steam people
watching this video and they keep
thinking nurse it's their scene I should
turn it off I keep forgetting it's like
5:00 in the morning so I didn't think
anyone would message me I think it's
safe or is it thinking it saves never a
good idea when he played this game
obviously holy [ __ ]
all right we're good
he walked so weird he's like strut that
ass strut that ass strut that ass strut
that ass ooh you both had Arsenal and
the padlock what [ __ ] a padlock
I guess
I gotta continue my journey from where I
saw the monster
is there something I'm missing here
let's check no it's cuz I feel kind of
loss no that's great so we're in hair
lost with a monster this is a padlock
don't slice up my bro bro
yes you are a cockroach yes no one likes
it this is where I came from talk don't
talk
Daniel supposed to be quiet
sorry that was my steam again
where'd I come from I come from here
right
yeah probably forgot something
kitchen let's head in there sorry my
steam again he just won't [ __ ] type
to me
alright let's lift this up so we don't
forget where we came from
am i walking back now I kinda feel like
I am
yeah this is where it came from but
what's over here then it's another way
to the kitchen
here
what budge
it won't go away let's try picklock no
let's just try all this stuff and get
this over with
what [ __ ] I'll ask your I really expect
that to work am i that's stupid
alright I don't know why I keep trying
that I know it's not gonna work
thinks we're gonna head to the kitchen
actually alright I have Athena Wow
it's all there not creepy
I don't want it to him to sneak up on me
alright August 1839 I feel like I have
fled the world and all its worries oh
there's a majestic creation perched upon
a forest clad Hill with towers reaching
well above even the highest pine tree
following the winding road leading to
the gates gives the impression of
discovering something forgotten as if
journeying with Marco Polo to the hidden
Xanadu Alexander the Baron is a peculiar
but gracious man and his owns all versed
in worldly matters and is not at all as
eccentric as I assumed my room is
exquisite and I'm confident that no
hotel for miles could even hope to match
it oh oh the Sun sets on brennenburg its
fairytale varnish turns to an eerie
gloom Alexander's strange servants are
never far away they are a quiet lot and
their behavior could only be described
as [ __ ] stall ganking
aleksander seems pleased by my presence
of course it says can't but rape you it
seems like I got here just in time too
but rape yeah that didn't tell us much I
think we already knew that I bet there's
something I got finally oh geez
oh I'm turning this game off he is he
found if he finds me here
oh this was not a good hiding spot
it's got to be better hiding spots [ __ ]
oh why did I picked this hiding spot
[Music]
oh this is not a good hiding spot it's
gonna go for the pigs I don't want to
see it again
[ __ ] goosebumps my boss thinks games
stop creeping the hell out of me
I can't read my [ __ ] notes alone it's
your [ __ ] problem I think I'm safe
I hope am but I'm not checking until the
[ __ ] music stops
[Music]
I need that
jason joyce ah
[Music]
are we good we cool bro
all right
guess I gotta pick this up you're cool
bro all right
pigs and [ __ ]
maybe this can like I don't know what
it's called in English but destroy the
lock I don't know what you call it it
probably will hang on this part because
I don't this is too much for me my I got
to take a break or something I don't
know it's gonna take a split second for
you either way